robot chicken are you coming back for an
11th yes we're actually
uh are we shooting yeah we've written
the whole thing
we've got a half hour special that
hasn't been announced yet that i'm
incredibly excited about
um and then uh
and then yes a whole 11th season is on
the way well thanks for having me on by
the way that was a dream and i'm so glad
you got you had me on that was so funny
i was
super confused that you that you'd only
done it the one time
yeah i think i think overall this time
i've just assumed everybody has done it
so i'm always surprised when especially
a friend of mine is like hey why haven't
you ever
had me on the show and i'm like not on
purpose i don't know if i said that i
just said hey if you ever need me on
here's what happened i go hey if you
ever need a voice anything on robot
chicken you go
wait you haven't been on it no he goes
he goes yeah you'll get on it and i
immediately called our castle and i was
like please put rosenbaum on for
whatever comes up that was that's worth
his time
oh i would have done one line i would
have done i would have just yelled
hey i don't love that i love when people
come in and get to do something that's
why that's why we have everybody do
three parts well this news show blark
and sun on comedy series on comedy
central yeah
yeah i did i like i in an interview you
said this is like
you know it's the weirdest thing you've
done or maybe you put on instagram
and then i go okay let's see if how
weird seth's talking and then i watched
it i go whoa
this is fun i felt like i was watching
that phil
collins video in this all the world we
live in it was so it's
i love it yeah i love them
the junior characters oh just
the cat the you guys have to see this on
comedy central it is
so bizarre that i mean who came up with
this
that's all uh ben beyo the um uh
this is this is something i i haven't
had it sounds silly i haven't had to do
anything for this except consistently
affirm that it's a good idea
right so very very early on it's years
ago now
ben um wanted to produce
they showed us the puppets first and he
was like this is a thing
and then i can't even remember if you
filmed the demo or not
but they were gonna do it on instagram
and just just make it and so
we financed that and then it got picked
up from
instagram to be um do you remember when
verizon
had a platform for a second 90. so go90
came after us and was like we'll finance
uh a run of shorts and so we produced a
series of shorts for
them and then that whole thing went out
of business
and we got the rights back and sold it
to comedy
um to make an online series that also
rears on the network and i i again
i just think the thing is so
funny it's so creative
it's so strange it's full of incredible
performers
and unbelievable production value um
it is by far the weirdest thing
it's so weird it's so like you can't
stop watching it that's how weird it is
you can't stop watching these characters
like oh
these characters are so larger than life
and i'm just like going oh my god
i gotta keep watching this if you go to
the instagram page i might get high and
watch
shorts that uh that they filmed it's
it's just very very funny
and smart and really capture something
about um
family dynamics and then you know
neighborhood dynamics
um and the biggest thing is i love all
that
tech right because it's the exact same
stuff that you would use to make a
monster movie right so if you're gonna
make
american werewolf in london it's the
same principle
it's all the same machines and materials
and stuff so i've been
i've been trying to fortify that
department of our studio
so that we can render visual effects for
something that a future i want to make
you